[Musique]
retour à l'actualité au 1920 on disait
de Charles ernu qu'il avait réconcilier
les militaires et le socialisme il
préférait rappeler plus simplement qu'il
était fils de gendarme à Marseille des
indices pour les enquêteurs sur
l'assassinat du docteur Péchard mais
toujours aucune certitude sur le mobile
à Noyon le conseil de discipline du
collège Pasteur a définitivement exclu
les trois jeunes musulmanes qui
refusaient d'ôter leur chador le Coran
en BD une première les SEP tomes édités
en France destinés aux adolescents
musulmans soulèvent la colère des
extrémistes notamment en Tunisie Charles
Hernu est mort en tribin quelques
minutes après avoir une dernière fois
exhorté la foule c'était hier soir à
villeorbane nos confrères de FR3 lion
filmaient ce meeting en faveur de
l'Arménie maises chers amis
arméniens nous avons été un peu
illusionnés par ce qui s'est passé dans
les minutes plus tard à 22h15 Charles
her demandait à son voisin de lui
succéder au micro mais à peine rassis il
suffoquait avant de s'affesser en
grimaçant à 66 ans Charles Hern était en
train de mourir les soins qui allaient
lui être prodigué immédiatement par les
médecins présents dans la salle par les
sapeurs pompiers puis par le SAMU n'y
pourront
rien nous allons en peu de mots et peu
de séquen d'archives faire revivre toute
une vie d'abord Charles Hernu le
militant Jean-Marc
pit Charles Hernu cumule dans les années
d'après-g guerre sa carrière au Centre
national du commerce extérieur et son
activité de journaliste aux patriotes et
aux démocrates de Lyon il fonde en 1951
le club des Jacobins mais c'est Pierre
mandz- France qui le fera véritablement
naître à la politique à l'image de son
illustre Parin il sera un ardent
militant de l'anticolonialisme en 1956
il se présente aux élections
législatives et devient ainsi le plus
jeune député de France il rallie ensuite
le PSU mais en 1965 François mitéran
l'appelle à ses côtés pour sa campagne
présidentielle il est ensuite nommé
secrétaire général du contre
gouvernement mitéran de 66 à 68 puis il
préside la convention des institutions
républicaines qui contribuera à mettre
sur pied le Parti socialiste à partir de
71 il est membre du comité directeur de
ce parti il y crée également une
commission défense en 73 puis est nommé
en 79 délégué national de ce secteur
c'est à ville urbane qu'il retrouvera un
mandat électif il y est élu maire pour
la première fois en 77 puis député en 78
cette commune restera jusqu'à la fin le
siège de son activité militante mai 81
Charles Hernu l'homme des dossiers
militaires et nommé ministre de la
Défense septembre 85 il démissionne une
carrière politique interrompue à cause
de la célèbre affaire Greenpeace Charles
nu le ministre Morad bouche Charl nu à
la défense était dans l'ordre des choses
prs disposé par ses origines familiales
son père était gendarme Charles Hernu
avait choisi au sein du PS sa deuxème
famille l'armée même si après les
événements d'Algérie le kaki et le rose
ne faisaient pas bon ménage ce Breton
pignatre avait décidé de batailler ferme
pour convertir son parti à une vision
plus réaliste de la défense et de la
dissuasion nucléaire Fran tireur au
début il avait réussi à convaincre
François mitteran et les socialistes de
se rallier au choix Gauliste de la force
de frappe à 57 ans par la grâce du DI
mai 81 Charles Hernu recevait son bâton
de maréchal un nouveau ministre de la
Défense n'hésitez pas à aller sur le
terrain oui je suis le ministre de la
Défense
nationale étonnant comme réaction parce
qu'il croit que la carte d'identité il C
il croit pas que c'est le Ministre
pourtant il adorait paradé en tenue
militaire avec une dose de spectaculaire
en mai 85 par exemple en uniforme
d'officier de marine il fait son arrivée
en Nouvelle-Calédonie à bord d'un
sous-marin autre gloriool dont il était
fier la féminisation de l'armée et la
force d'action rapide mais histoire a
décidé de retenir autre chose de son
passage à la défense l'énorme bavure du
Rainbow Warrior l'affaire Greenpace qui
lui a coûté son poste et sa carrière
politique nationale auut trombre à son
tableau de chasse le dossier luicher
deux affaires de mystères qu'il emporte
avec
lui Charles Hernu s'exprimait assez
rarement sur lui-même c'est pourtant ce
qu'il avait accepté de faire pour le
divan d'Henry Chapier enregistré fin
novembre l'émission devait être diffusée
le 27 janvier les circonstances bien sûr
imposent qu' soit avancé d'une semaine
le divan de Charles Hernu sera programmé
ce samedi 20 janvier à 22h15 alors dans
cet entretien de 26 minutes nous avons
choisi un extrait où Charles Hernu parle
de la mort lui s attaché à la vie nous
l'écoutons peur non mais ça m'ennuie ça
m'ennuie mourit comme tout le monde ça
devrait pas exister ça devrait pas
exister voilà c'est quand même la vie
c'est quand même c'est quand même beau
c'est quand même agréable c'est des
charmes mais char si tout à coup vous
vous trouviez devant une sorte vous
souvenez C tribunal du temps de Mao où
on devait faire son autocritique alors
que diriez-vous parce que là je pense
que vous seriez libre de tout dire pour
Charles Hernu que direz-vous de lui je
voulais pas dire ça bah écoutez je sais
pas il y a une balance il y a les bonnes
actions il y a les mauvaises actions en
ce qui me concerne
convaincu que le le fléo le plateau de
la balance pens du côté des bonnes
actions donc je su pas inquiet je mérite
plus le paradis de
l'enferin voilà l'intégralité de cet
entretien samedi après-demain donc à
22h15 le divan d'Henri Chapier Charles
Hernu il est convenable que la
disparition d'un tel homme ne suscite
que des regrets mais pour Charles Hernu
il est bien vrai qu'il était respecté
par ses adversaires voici donc les
réactions à sa mort recueillies par Emil
wiicelli moi j'ai perdu un ami et la
France a perdu un bon serviteur et le
mouvement socialiste a perdu un militant
fidèle on sait jamais quel Mor on peut
se souhaiter soi-même mais je suis sûr
que ça correspond bien à l'image qu'il
avait de lui c'était un combattant pour
les bonnes
causes charlnus c'était un homme du
peuple au sens plein et noble du terme
et qui d'ailleurs a toujours gardé ce
contact a toujours été fidèle à ses
racines populaires et il a traversé la
vie politique il a exercé des fonctions
très importantes il l'a toujours fait en
restant au contact en relation avec les
siens il savait qui l'avait mis là où il
était et ça dans la vie politique ce
n'est pas toujours le le cas ça c'était
très bien vous c'est un homme qui euh a
toujours démontré capacité de tolérance
et de respect des autres dans le débat
dans le débat d'opinion différentes et
aussi qui à un certains moment sur des
dossiers i il a fait preuve de courage
le gaouiste que je suis ne peut pas
mentionner ne pas mentionner que dans
les années 60 c'était difficile
d'imposer au Parti socialiste
l'acceptation de l'idée de dissuasion
nucléaire je dais Hernu il aime
tellement l'armée qu'il va finir par
donner le café au lait au lit au soldat
quoi et je disais aussi à Paris quand il
a défilé du 14 juillet là qui voit
défilè l'armée française il sontit de
joie en disant tout ça c'est à moi il
enevenenait pas obsèque de Charles Hernu
samedi à villeorbane les obsèques
auxquels assistera François miteran le
président de la République qui est
arrivé aujourd'hui à Budapest pour une
visite de 2 jours en Hongrie l'Europe de
l'Est où les événements continuent de
s'enchaîner nous allons le voir euh en
Roumanie en Bulgarie en Pologne mais
tout de suite et encore une fois dans le
caucas soviétique Caroline
[Musique]
SS première journée de François miteran
en Hongrie thème central de ce voyage
l'avenir et l'organisation l'EUR
monsieur mitan encore une fois promu son
idée de confédération européenne bien
accueillie par les Hongrois demain il
recevra les opposants et s'inclinera sur
la tombe
d'imrenag véritable guerre civile en
azerbaïjan les combats entre azérie et
Arméniens ont fait au moins 66 morts et
220 blessés plus de 20000 volontaires
Arméniens sont prêts à partir se battre
les frontières entre l'URS l'Iran et la
Turquie sont fermé à Bakou les Azéris
s'opposent toujours à l'entrée des chars
soviétiques
Todor gifkov l'ex-président de Bulgarie
est en prison et une instruction est
ouverte contre lui motif a répandu
l'hostilité nationale détourné des fonds
publics et abusé de son pouvoir giifkov
a été limogé le 10 novembre dernier
après avoir dirigé le pays pendant 35
ans les Roumains ne donneront pas leur
avis le référendum sur le rétablissement
de la peine de mort et l'interdiction du
PC est annulé il était prévu le 28
janvier pour le front de salut national
il n'a plus de raison d'être et n'aura
pas
lieu Marian kalalpa Premier ministre
tchécoslovaque vient de rendre sa carte
du PC le 10 décembre dernier c'est lui
qui formait le gouvernement de coalition
actuellement au pouvoir il ne reste plus
que se communistes sur 21
ministres le chador ou la porte elles
ont préféré garder leur chador et bien à
l'unanimité moins une voix le conseil de
discipline du collège Pasteur de Noyon
dans loise a voté l'exclusion définitive
de Nadia de Jamila et de Siam toutes
trois se sont livré à un militantisme au
sentatoire c'est donc la porte cette
décision du conseil de discipline
intervient après l'échec de longues
négociation depuis la rentrée les trois
élèves vont être inscrites d'office dans
un autre établissement de la ville
déclare ce soir l'inspecteur d'académie
de loise tout de suite les réactions à
Noyon André
Blondet vous pensez de l'exclusion de
vos camarades B c'est que cétait pas
bien pourquoi
P que ils
on on en démocratie sera peut-être temps
qu'il le prouve aussi hein je pense que
c'est bien dans un sens quoi parce que
ici comment on est en France puis on
devrait faire comme tout le monde quoi
nous les comprenons nous avons essayé de
les comprendre et de dialoguer nous
comprenons tout à fait leur position
mais je les ai souvent invité à
comprendre aussi notre position c'est
celle de défendre un service public qui
est le nôtre nous n'avons pas pu
rencontrer NAD est jamais là les trois
jeunes filles et leurs parents sont
restés enfermés chez eux à réfléchir
sans doute au choix qui leur est
maintenant offert changer
d'établissement Scola ou bien suivre des
cours par correspondance en tout cas si
pour cette famille la foi musulmane l'a
emporté les valeurs de la laïcité se
sont affirmé à Noyon d'une manière
unanime la décision d'exclure ces trois
élèves fera désormais jurisprudence en
matière de foulard islamique alors sans
vouloir inventer une nouvelle affaire de
chador comment ne pas signaler la
parution d'un un corant en bande
dessinée oui c'est une première édité en
France ces SEP tomes destinés aux aux
adolescents musulmans pardon a soulevé
l'indignation des intégristes notamment
en Tunisie les versets sataniques numéro
2 le reportage de
hour Youssef sedic journaliste tunisien
auteur du Coran en bande dessinée une
entreprise pédagogique qui vient d'être
condamné par le Conseil supérieur
islamique de Tunisie impossible de
représenter le Coran sans frôer le
sacrilège l'universitaire cétien vous a
même traité de salmam ri numéro 2 alors
quelle a été votre réaction c'est ce que
je craignais et la chose est arrivée euh
je savais que il y aurait des des gens à
la fois pervers intelligents et
dogmatiques dans la société musulmane
pour traiter mon livre comme ça Youssef
séic n'en est pas à son coup d'cès en
1986 après consultation de plusieurs
conseils islamiques il avait renoncé à
son premier projet de BD coranique jugé
irrespectueux cette fois Youssef sedic
se rebiffe il affirme avoir envoyé son
projet aux autorités religieuses et
avoir tenu compte de leurs conseils
ainsi seul un rayon lumineux symbolise
les prophètes une religion qui ne sait
pas rire ce n'est pas une religion et
que l'islam dangereux c'est celui qui
n'a pas d'humour reste que ce début de
polémique fait peur à l'Institut du
monde arabe la librairie indépendante a
décidé d'arrêter la vente des
livres public a très bien réagi on avait
un stock limité qui est parti jusque
dimanche dernier et vous souhaitez le
renouveler ce
stock une fois que les esprits sont
calmés pourvu que ça touche pas les
sensibilité arabo
mususulman à Marseille dans l'enquête
sur l'assassinat du docteur Péchard les
policiers disposent semble-t-il de
quelques indices un homme d'une
cinquantaine d'années grisonnant aperçu
au volant d'une Renault 20 et puis un
mystérieux client du restaurant où dînit
le maire du 7e secteur de Marseille
mardi soir oui les enquêteurs espèrent
pouvoir établir bientôt les portraits
robot bref ce meurtre ainsi que les
autres affaires criminelles de ces
derniers temps a jeté un véritable
trouble sur la canne bière mais tout de
suite le point sur l'enquête concernant
le crime du docteur Péchard Dominique
gonau Jean-Jacques Péchard a été abattu
de deux coups de chevrotine tel est le
résultat de l'autopsie pratiquée
aujourd'hui les policiers poursuivent
leurs investigations encore beaucoup de
flou autour des circonstances du drame
23h15 hier deux hommes à bord d'une
Renault 20 interceptent la voiture du
maire du 7e secteur de Marseille le
passager de la R20 sort et tire selon
certains témoins il portait une cagoule
et tiré de la main gauche un inspecteur
affirme au contraire que les deux hommes
ont agi à visage découvert qu'ils
étaient blancs le conducteur serait un
homme d'une cinquantaine d'années ce
soir la personnalité du docteur Péchard
est en tout cas au centre de l'enquête
les policiers fouille sont passé plus
agités qu'il ne paraît ils mettent en
avant la thèse d'un règlement de compte
lié un motif d'ordre
privé voilà donc pour l'enquête sur la
mort du docteur Péchard situation de
blocage ce soir à l'agence France-
presse au conseil d'administration les
représentants des pouvoir public se sont
opposés avec succès à la réélection du
président de la FP monsieur Jean-Louis
guilla qui était seul en LCE trois tours
de scrutin pour rien la semaine
prochaine il appartiendra au Conseil
supérieur de l'Agence France Presse de
proposer deux candidats à la présidence
voici à présent le Tour de France de
l'actualité avec les images des 25
stations de la 3 et les commentaires de
natel grève des gardes et des urgen des
internes à partir de demain la nuit
dernière les discussions entre les
médecins grevis et le ministère de la
santé n'ont pas abouti une autre
rencontre est prévue d'ici 24 Hees pour
l'intersyndicat national des médecins
hospitaliers la grve des urgence n'est
cependant pas une solution elle porte
atteinte aux exigences d'accueil et de
soins des
malades 2 mois à 2 ans d'emprisonnement
3000 à 40000 francs d'amende
l'inculpation de Pierre Bernard maire de
Montfermeil a été rendu publique par
Pierre Jox et Lionel Jospin début
janvier le conseil municipal avait
supprimé tout service d'entretien dans
deux école maternelle de Montfermeil une
décision aussitôt dénoncée par le
gouvernement pour Pierre-Bernard cette
inculpation ne fait qu'éluder le vrai
problème trop d'émigrés dans sa
commune la commercialisation des huîtres
et des moules de l'étan de TH à nouveau
autorisé depuis aujourd'hui l'étan avait
été fermé le 14 décembre dernier après
la découverte de salmonnelle dans les
coquillages une fermeture qui au moment
des fêtes de fin d'année a fait perdre
quelques 60 millions de francs aux
austriculteurs aujourd'hui l'état
sanitaire de l'État ne présenterait plus
aucun risque pour la santé
publique
dans votre région en France et dans le
monde voilà donc ce qu'il fallait
retenir aujourd'hui de l'actualité
Catherine ce soir c'est un peu plus que
bonsoir que vous nous dites et bien oui
l'équipe actuelle du du 1920 passe le
relais à Paul Hamard lundi prochain
bonne chance à lui bien sachez que que
j'ai pris beaucoup de plaisir pendant
ces deux années à vous présenter ce
journal vraiment pas comme les autres on
tourne la page mais j'aurais cet autre
plaisir de vous retrouver non plus une
fois par jour mais c fois imaginé entre
14h et 18h merci beaucoup pour votre
lité et à bientôt voilà donc qui n'a
rien de triste on retrouvera Catherine
toutes les heures de l'après-midi entre
14 et 18h en alternance avec Didier
chaumon c'est cela tout à fait complet
et alors nous sommes ici sur la péniche
de talasa gentiment hébergé par nos amis
de talasa parce qu'en ce moment bien on
refait le studio là-bas à quelques 300 m
d'ici pour les nouvelles éditions qui
débutent lundi ce soir prochain
rendez-vous d'actualité sur la 3 c'est
Soir 3 Philippe deessin notre ami
Philippe DIN à 22h20 et puis auparavant
un film fil film le Gitan avec Alain
Delon Annie Gerardo
voilà pour votre soirée sur la 3 merci
bonsoir tout de suite la météo complète
de Michel Touray déjà le weekend qui
s'annonce excellente
soirée